Congratulations.
You've answered a question that was vitally important for centuries.
How can we locate our ships at sea?
You've seen that even though finding latitude is relatively easy,
finding your longitude can be incredibly difficult.
With a reliable time-keeping mechanism, which we can create by taking advantage
of simple harmonic motion, we can find our longitude by comparing the time on our ship
to the time at some known location.
In the next unit, we're going to visit the 18th century
when buildings were frequently struck by lightening.
In the next unit, we're going to answer the question how can we prevent
buildings from being struck by lightening. See you then.